It’s been an exciting couple of months in
Kaiapoi’s Regeneration areas.
Earlier this month, the new Community BMX
track was officially opened.
There was a great turnout from keen riders,
both young and old, who lined up try out the track.
The opening had been highly anticipated
and the ribbon was cut by Olympian Trent Jones,
who designed and built the track.
Designing the track, I wanted to be able to
cater for a wider audience of cycling and
BMX, and that stemmed from beginners who have
never ridden a BMX track before, all the way
to myself who has been fully professional.
Many of the people attending, including Trent,
were members of the old Kaiapoi BMX club.
They lost their club track as a result of
damage caused by September 2010 earthquake.
It’s kinda cool to be able to build this
one and reinstate a BMX track here after growing
up in Kaiapoi riding the tracks.
In the Town Centre, the Kaiapoi Marine Precinct
is now open for business, following dredging
over winter and the installation of the final
112 metre floating pontoon.
The Council has already received several applications
for long-term berths.
Space has also been set aside for casual and
short-term use, and for the River Queen.
The Kaiapoi Dog Park is also nearly ready,
with the walking tracks, fences,
and gates all complete.
It has separate areas for small and large
dogs, and is expected to open to the public
in a few weeks’ time once the grass is fully
established.
Next door, a recent Community Planting Day
saw residents and visitors planting another
600 native seedlings in the Honda Forrest.
The Regeneration focus now turns towards the
sports fields, with tenders recently sought
for the construction of the changing facilities,
softball diamonds and surrounding roads.